we have some very important news
Buckingham Palace has just announced
that her majesty Queen Elizabeth II has
died
she was the longest reigning monarch in
British history
and the world's oldest head of state
her eldest son in Heir Charles the
former Prince of Wales is now the king
whatever may be your background or
beliefs
I shall Endeavor to serve you with
loyalty respect and love
anyway
[Music]
and that your majesty concludes today's
business for the council
[Music]
God Save the King
[Applause]
foreign
she was a patent to all Prince's Libby
as I stand before you today
I cannot help but feel the weight of
History which surrounds us and which
reminds us of the vital parliamentary
traditions
oh God I hate it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and that my soul
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
foreign
foreign
through all the years of her Reign the
land of Wales could not have been closer
to my mother's heart
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]